understanding css media queries is
essential if you're gonna create
responsive websites
joy does an excellent job explaining how
they work
in this comprehensive course hey guys
joy here in this video we're gonna learn
css media queries and we're gonna also
build three practical projects so let's
go
okay the first question is what are css
media queries and why should you even
care
if you want to make responsive websites
like this you can see that
this is the desktop version and this is
the mobile version for the same website
you might be in situations where you
have to design four different version of
the same website
one for the tablet one for the desktop
one for the
laptop and another one for the mobile
version so these are all possible using
css media queries and you should
definitely learn it
so we're building this website on
project 2. on the third project we're
going to be building this so this is the
mobile version
and this is the desktop version and
we're going to build this on the first
project you can see that when we drag
the window over here
you can see that our numbers i mean the
width of our window
changes live like this and also the
color of
the background changes depending on the
breakpoints we have defined
on our media queries don't worry we're
gonna discuss that also
so at the bottom we can see that we have
define our breakpoints over here
and depending on that our colors will
change
so we're going to learn first of all
little bit and then write little bit of
code
so little bit of learning little bit of
doing
by the way i have an entire article on
css media queries
through illustrations i beautifully
explain each and every aspect of css
media queries so that you can either
revise
or learn media 4 is very easily quickly
and
efficiently if you're new to the channel
feel free to subscribe because i post
videos based on practical wave type
projects so that you can level up your
coding skills
if that's so interesting hit the
subscribe button and join my gang and
without further ado
let's get started all right boys and
girls before coding first of all we need
to set up our environment to do that
come to the window over here right click
create a new folder okay
and then name it anything you wish i'm
gonna name it project
one project one like this and then i'm
gonna open it on
vs code right click and you're gonna get
this option of open with vs code
if you don't get it what you're gonna do
is you're gonna open a vs code
then you're gonna click this file option
over here and then
open folder
okay so come to the desktop and then you
can see the project one over here
select folder and now we can see that it
has
opened our folder over here click this
plus sign
and write index.html
okay and then for this project we're
gonna use sas not css because it is
more powerful and it has more options
than regular css
even if you're a beginner start learning
sas along with css
because it's gonna be very handy and
it's gonna save you a lot of time
so click this icon again and write style
dot sc ss okay and then we're gonna
create
for another file named main.js
main.js the main purpose of creating
this
javascript file is that um if you come
back over here you can see that
this is loading live okay so if i resize
the window you can see the value
live for this we're gonna use javascript
so don't worry about it it's
very little javascript on project 2
we're going to learn how we can make
responsive images
along with our responsive website so for
that you need to download some images
the images are on my github repository
the link of the github repository is
given in the description down below so
once you click on the link
you're going to copy the link from here
control c and then if you scroll down
you're going to find these steps or you
can follow along with me
you click on down get you go there
and you paste the link that you copied
earlier over here and you click this
download option and it's gonna create
the folder
why are we doing this that's because
github doesn't have
a direct download link let me show you
if i go back
you can see that we don't have a
download option over here
all right so now you're going to drag
this outside
it is actually a zip file so media query
project is the name of the folder over
here
it contains uh five images
okay so once that's done you're gonna
rename the
folder and name it to uh
images wait if you rename if you click
on here
or you can also click f2 to rename the
file
i mean folder so you can write images
like this
and now what you can do is you can
either drag this inside
or you open vs code over here and then
you drag the images folder over here to
copy it
so now you're going to click copy folder
like this
and now your project folder should look
like this okay and now
you write this sign and then hit tab
this is emmet if emma doesn't work for
you search google why
emmett is not working on vs code you're
gonna find appropriate solutions
now what you're gonna do is you're gonna
link the sas
and the javascript file inside the html
follow me
link you hit tab okay and then you write
style dot sas like this so we are
linking this sas
file inside our html and in order to
link the main.js come below the body
over here
at the middle over here okay so you
write script
ah there is the option and over here you
write
main.js like this ctrl s
and we are done change the document to
media query practice
and inside over here you write dot
container
i n e r tab container tab and then
inside over here we're gonna
create a div with the class name text
like this dot
text tab and over here you write hello
screen
ctrl s and then below the container not
inside the container below the container
you're gonna create a d
with the id size like this follow me
hashtag size tab so this is an
id and don't forget that this is not
inside over here
not inside the container it is outside
the container over here
okay so this will carry the width of our
window
let me show you again if you come back
to this
pane over here you can see that this is
actually showing us live
okay and this is our id
inside our html which is uh this one
we're gonna style this and then give it
some function
inside the javascript so ctrl s we're
done with our html
and now come to the sas part oh you also
need to download some extensions
so if you can't see this activity bar
over here what you're gonna do
you click this view and you click
appearance and you're gonna get this
activity bar okay and if you can't see
actually
if you can't see the blue ribbon over
here you come to view and then
appearance and then you hit that
status bar okay so this is called status
bar and this is called
activity bar so you come over to
extensions and you hit uh you write
live says not
live sorry sas compiler okay
and you're gonna get this over here
uh not this sorry live says compiler
you're going to install live sas
compiler okay
and the next thing that you're gonna
install is
live server
or this one you're going to install this
one once you have installed the
extensions come back to our sas file
and we also need to remove the default
styles of our browser in order to do
that
you hit star curly braces and you set
margin
padding to zero pixels each to do that
m0px
tap p0px tap and set the box size into
border box to do that
both side tap okay bobo
a tab which is borderbox emmett does all
the shortcuts for us
now we're gonna set the font family
inside the body
as sans serif okay s a and s
save like this we're gonna set the font
size to 35
pixels like this f size tab
35 pixels all right we're done
styling our default
styles you hit save and then what you're
gonna do
you can see this small option over here
which is watch
sas you're gonna click this okay so once
you have clicked on it
you're gonna get two files generated
over here which is style.css
and style.css.map why is that
that's because the browser can't run our
sas file directly needs
to convert from sas to css and then we
can see it on our browser
that's why it is generating us this file
over here
and you can see that this is all css
converted css from sas to css
so now you're gonna come back to our
index.html
and from here you're gonna remove the s
and convert it to css from sas
control s don't forget to save okay and
now you're gonna run this on our
browser in order to do that you can
either get an option over here which is
open live server or if you can't see the
option over here like myself
you're gonna what you're gonna do is
right click over here
and you can see this option open with
live server
click on it
and now it is running on live server on
our browser congratulations
okay so now let's come back to our vs
code
the next thing that we're going to do is
come to main.js
and we also need to now come back to the
main.js file and over here we're going
to write some
very little bit of javascript so that we
can actually run this
on our project which is this one
which is which will show us the life
value of our width
of our screen so you have to do that
follow along with me
so first of all you write window don't
worry i'm going to explain
little by little what each line means so
window dot
on resize equal to screen okay
and then write window dot
on load equal to
screen okay and then we're gonna create
a function over here function
named screen okay
and inside over here you're gonna write
my width
equal to window
dot inner
width over here okay okay now
let me explain the javascript what i
have written so let's start with the
window thing over here
this entire vs code is a window okay
this entire google chrome is a window so
now
on resize and on reload let me explain
to you
so if you come back to our browser over
here i mean the project one
if you resize it like this and now you
can see that
value changes so it is happening live so
the function over here on load is
working on resize what is happening if
you
stretch it like this on resize is
working
so it is loading live so which is
um this one on load and my width equal
to windows
inner width is working to show us the
length
from here to here i mean the width
so that's how this thing is working and
now we also need to display it on our
browser
so let me come back to our project so we
want to
display it over here okay in order to do
that um
we're gonna write we need to target our
id over here which is this one okay in
order to target that exact thing
what you're gonna write is document dot
get element by id that's because it is
an
id if it was a class then we would have
written
get element by class name don't worry
about this i'm gonna create an
entire video on this topic in the future
so
you're gonna write codes and then size
over here because
the name was size and then dot inner
html like this so the main purpose of
inner html is to insert text
inside our div with the class name of
size over here okay
and now we're gonna write equal to and
now we're gonna write some text okay
with colon okay and then you're gonna
hit plus sign
let me save it and show you what is
happening i remove the plus and just
colon okay
and now back to the browser we can't see
anything
because we made a mistake over here
that's why we can't see anything
you write screen ctrl s and now we can
see our
text over here all right and now what
we're gonna write is we want
it um we want the width to be shown over
here
in order to do that um what you're gonna
write
is you hit plus sign over here and you
write the name of this variable okay
so you write my width like this ctrl
s and now we can see the value over here
so this is the pixel value
um you come back to vs code and you
write another
small word plus and then
quotes pixels px control
s and now it is displaying successfully
now let's bring it at the middle at the
center over here
okay so come back to vs code um let me
remove
this because we don't need the activity
bar and we also don't need this bar from
here
the status bar all right and we're also
done with the main.js file we don't need
it so you can
minimize it okay and if you want to
minimize this
as well you hit control b if you hit
ctrl b
again then this panel will come back
okay so ctrl b and now on the sas
file you target the container text and
the size
hashtag size so dot container
container curly braces like this
you target the text the text like this
and you target the size hashtag size
like this
all right so now we want the hello text
to be at the very center in order to do
that first of all we need to define the
size
i mean the height of our container if
you don't you find the height what
happens is let me show you
let's define some border around our
container okay
border of let's say 4px solid
red okay ctrl s minimize this
and now we can see that the container is
just this portion of
our browser but we want it to be at the
maximum
otherwise we can't work properly so in
order to do that come back to vs code
you set the height over here to 100 vh
which is the whole screen height control
s
and now we can see that the container
has stretched
from here to here and now we can work
with our project
successfully back to vs code you remove
the border from here
ctrl s and you can see the text has
our width has come to the very bottom
over here we want it to be at the very
center
and this one over here as well so come
back to vs code you can center the hello
text
in two ways you can either use the
display grid or you can also use the
display
flex let me show both of them okay first
write d
flex okay tap if you write justify
content
to center then it is going to work on
the x-axis
okay let me show you so you can see that
the hello screen has moved to the center
of the x-axis
this is the x-axis and this is the
y-axis all right
so now back to vs code if you want to
keep it at the center
along the y-axis what you have to write
is align
con align items center
ctrl s minimize this and let's see you
can see that this is at the very center
and if you want to use the grid what you
have to write is d
grid tab display grid and place
items in the shorthand of both the x and
y
axis so place content
center like this and you
comment this from here ctrl s minimize
it
and you can see that it's still working
and now we need to place this text
at the very center over here at the
bottom of
hello screen back to the back to vs code
um you come at the bottom over here you
write first of all position absolute
post apps tap position absolute
and then top 50 or not 50
um 60 like this left 50 percent
like this and let's see what is giving
us the result
um you can see that it is over here but
we want it to be at the very center
but it is not working why is that let me
explain to you on the x-axis i have
defined 50 percent
so from here to here it is 50
but actually this is the center okay
it should have worked from here to here
but it is working from here
to here so in order to fix that you have
to write the transform property
transform and then translate
x which is the x-axis you can also work
with the y-axis but
not for this tutorial i'm gonna make an
entire video on the transform property
so make sure to subscribe so that you
can get an update about this
okay so translate x minus 50
okay ctrl s and now we can see that our
problem has been solved over here
back to over here you also set the font
size to 35 pixels
font size 35 pixels like this ctrl
s and we are done come back to the
container over here and you give it a
color of
bgc tap um set it to white for now uh if
i come back to my
blog over here i have defined a lot of
colors um wait
so these are the colors over here i'm
gonna copy it from here don't write
right now i'm gonna give you a moment
so control uh copy from here come
back to our vs code on the sas at the
very top okay
over here i'm gonna paste it over here
now pause the video take a moment to
write these lines of code over here and
don't forget to write the dollar sign
otherwise
it is not gonna work so these are called
variables
so i'm storing our color hex values over
here
and then we're gonna use it all along
inside our project
every time if you need to change
something you don't have to go through
and read the entire document what you
have to do is you just change over here
and then the entire document will be
changed
that's why sas is more powerful than
regular css and it saves
us a lot of time we're gonna also define
our breakpoints inside variables
and then we're gonna use it to define
our media queries
i'm gonna show that to you don't worry
about this and yeah i got these colors
from this website over here which is
coolers dot go let me show you
if you visit the website you can find
tons of colors over here you can choose
any color you want
for your projects link of this website
will be given in the description down
below so that you can go and check it
out
okay now back to vs code on the
container you remove this let me show
you a sample of how these variables work
so it was hashtag fff which defined the
white color
and if you want to bring this color one
over here i don't know what is the name
but let's say this is purple because i'm
seeing
purple over here so if you want to bring
that purple color over here what you
have to write is
dollar sign color
1 ctrl s and now you can see that the
color 1
which is the purple color has been
applied over here oh
come back to the vs code and on this
hashtag size you change the color to red
so that we can
better see what we are trying to do ctrl
s
and now we can see that we have achieved
our desired
result okay now we're done with our
setup let's start the tutorial
let's say that i'm your friend and you
don't even recognize me in these cases
what i have to do is i have to tell my
name to you
my name is joy in the same way we have
to tell the
browser that we are defining a media
query
that's why we write the term at the red
media to tell the browser that
recognize this this is a media query
and then we write conditions over here
like screen
and then max width
let's set it to let's say 768 pixels
and we also write the min width over
here
let's say it was let's say 768 pixels
like this
so this media query at the right media
query is a declaration
telling the browser that we are starting
a media query from here
and these are our conditions the screen
which is the media type
and max width mean with these are our
conditions don't worry about this i'm
going to explain
in details about each and every
condition over here
okay and then inside this curly braces
we're gonna define our styles over here
okay your styles
are here so once the browser recognizes
our media query
and then if our styles i mean if our
conditions are met
then all the styles that we have defined
here will be applied on our browser
as simple as that and you might have
seen these operators the comma
and the and operator let me explain this
to you right now
let's say you have gone to a restaurant
and you have ordered two things
burger and a pizza so write this
burger and pizza okay
let's say that your friend has ordered
burger
pizza and coca-cola like this
burger uh you write coma okay
pizza and cooka
sorry okay hold on like this
so let's see what is happening burger
and pizza two different commands
okay it is separated by what a
and and these three things you see these
are separated by
a comma and the end in the same way
these are our commands okay so if you
have
if you have uh let's say that just two
commands
so what we're gonna write is the and
operator over here okay
but if you have three or more then
you're gonna use the comma
and the end operator like this so let's
say you have
three commands so ctrl v which is the
min width you're gonna write and over
here and
you're not gonna write n you're gonna
write comma over here and then it's
gonna work
so let's remove them i hope you
understood the
operators coma and the and operator
now let's discuss about the media type
in total you have four options
all print screen and speech don't worry
about all of these values because you're
gonna use the
screen option to make responsive website
for
electronic devices even if you don't
declare the media type it's gonna set it
to all
this one automatically so skim through
this chart over here
i hope you understood the media type
over here you can write either screen
all or you can keep it blank and it's
gonna automatically define it to all
now let's discuss about the max width
function what this does is it creates
us a border okay so when we are inside
that border it's gonna work but
if we go outside that border it's not
gonna work
so see this illustration over here you
can see that
the styles are applied inside this 500
pixels but
if we go outside the border of 500
pixels it is not gonna
apply the styles it's gonna be blank
white let me show you a demo about this
so over here you write bracket max
width let's say to um
500 pixels over here okay ctrl s
you come back to our results screen over
here you can see that this is a purple
color
and let's say that um we're gonna set it
to
bgc tab okay let's set it to
uh the hashtag sorry not hashtag dollar
sign
color one like this okay ctrl s and you
come back to our container over here
so you remove this from here and you
write
uh hashtag fff which defines the white
color okay
now minimize this and you hit f12
f12 and now if we resize the window
oh that's because you also need to write
the name of the selector
in order to do that uh what you're going
to do is you remove this over here and
you're going to write the selector
the container selector okay dot co and p
i
n e r over here curly braces
and then you divide if and then you
define it over here
like this ctrl s and now it's going to
work okay
now to minimize this so this you can see
that we have set our boundary to 500
pixels as long as we're inside the 500
pixels
the color will be applied but if we go
outside then it's not gonna
get applied so you can see that we are
at 787 pixels and the color is not
getting applied
if you resize the window like this you
can see the color is getting applied
which means that we're inside the border
it is
447 pixels but if we go outside the
border
um wait let me resize this uh this is
499 pixels and it is the color purple
if you resize it it is 579 pixels and it
is white the color is not getting
applied
i hope you understood the max width
function let's talk about the main width
function
so this is the same thing inside the
border it is not going to work
if you go outside the border then it's
gonna work
let me show you a demo and then you're
gonna
get clear about this okay now come back
to vs code and from here you write
min with okay let me give a practical
demo
let's say that i am over here i live in
bangladesh
and we don't have starbucks so outside
my border let's say this is america okay
so america has starbucks
so inside the border here i am if i go
outside
the border which is if i go to america
then i'm gonna get
starbucks but if i stay inside the
border
then i'm not gonna get in starbucks in
the same way
inside the min width our styles will not
get applied
but if we get outside the border our
styles will get
applied okay so now on the vs code
we just change the mean width from max
width you come back to the result screen
over here
did we save it no we didn't save it this
is very crucial you need to save your
code otherwise it's not gonna work
ctrl s come back to the browser and now
we are actually outside the border which
was our border
500 pixels okay so now you resize the
window like this
um so we are inside the border and our
styles are not getting applied
but if you resize the window let's say
uh 40
489 pixels this is inside the border
okay
outside the board inside the border
outside the border
i hope you understood the mean with
function and now we're going to write
the code itself
to be honest there is no such thing as a
standard media query breakpoints
because of various screen sizes on the
market
for this tutorial i'm gonna use the
official bootstrap five
breakpoint chart if you click this link
over here
then you can see the various standard
screen breakpoints defined by bootstrap
five
so if you scroll down you can see all
the values over here
and we're gonna define all of these
breakpoints inside variables so that we
can easily
manage our code so if you scroll down
you're gonna find all of these values
over here so i'm gonna copy them
ctrl c and at the very top okay i'm
gonna paste it over here
review now pause the video
and write these values over here and
also don't forget to write the dollar
sign at first
otherwise it's not gonna work so this is
the breakpoint for the mobile version
this is the break from the this is the
breakpoint for the tablet
laptop and the dexter version 576 pixels
and so on now how we are gonna use this
is
if you come back to the media query at
the very bottom
you can see that this is 500 pixels okay
so this is writing directly
instead of writing directly over here we
write the variable okay dollar sign
mobile b-i-l-e like this
and automatically the 576 pixels uh
which is this one
this value is 576 pixels is applied
over here okay now the cool feature of
writing
like this is that if you need to change
something let's say you need to change
the media query you have to go through
all
these lines of code you have to read all
of them which is
a very big headache so if you write like
this
using variables throw says if you need
to change something
you don't have to go through all of the
files all of the lines of code you just
need to change it over here
how simple is that that's why you should
use sas
even if you're a beginner all right then
let's complete our project one and let's
move to project two
okay so in order to complete this
uh not min width we're gonna write max
width okay and then we're gonna set the
color
which is uh i have regenerated on the
comment so color one is for the mobile
version color two for the tablet and so
on so in order to
do that uh this is actually perfect and
then we're gonna write
at the red media for the
tablet max width
dollar sign tablet like this and over
here we're gonna write container
and curly braces bgc tab
and define dollar sign color to over
here
okay a very quick tip if you want to
define media queries
first you're gonna write the biggest
screen at the
first and then smallest screen at the
bottom
it's a descending order so the largest
will be at the first
and descending descending and the
smallest will be at the bottom
if you don't do this then it's not gonna
work let me show you a demo
okay so you come back to the browser um
over here
so the color one which was purple color
it is not working look
look the color is not even changing
but if you write it in the reverse order
let me show you
so this is the mobile smallest one first
largest one
later but if you write in the reverse
order ctrl
x and you paste it over here ctrl v
ctrl s and then minimize it and now it's
working look
resized it this is purple color look um
look it's 567 pixels if you resize it
then it's going to change the color over
here and on the 768
i guess yes 768 mark then it's gonna
change the color back to white which is
the default color we defined it over
here on the container which is this one
and let's define our desktop and laptop
as well
first smaller screen first okay me
tia not screen max
with sorry with
dollar sign laptop like this and over
here we're gonna write dot com
day nerf curly braces
then bgc bgc tab
dollar sign color
free ctrl s okay the
then copy this paste it over here
you just change the value from here to
desktop okay
and then the color will be color number
four
control s and we're done with our
project one let's go and test it
so you resize the window you can see the
color is changing
perfectly okay so this is desktop
version this is the laptop version
tablet mobile i hope you understood
project one let's move on to project two
so we're gonna be building this for
project two let's start
minimize this come back to our
vs code control b okay
now what we're gonna do we're gonna
remove some code from here okay
so remove these variables we don't need
them anymore
okay so over here we can keep it
you need to change the font size from
here okay
and don't delete this uh it's not
working that's because
uh we also need to change this media
queries from here that's because we
don't need them
so in total we have four media queries
from the project one
delete them and don't remove the size
from here otherwise
we can't see our width of our screen
live
okay minimize this just don't remove it
and remove all of the code from here
and then ctrl s back to index.html
don't remove the size from here okay you
just remove this
text from here ctrl s
all right so we are pretty much done
back to the
design now on the project you can see
that we have the logo over here
and the menu items over here let's
consider this
header okay and the content over here
the image and this text over here is the
main
and this this one which contains the
social media links will be our footer
header main and the footer okay so in
order to create them
come back to vs code and inside the
container
we're going to create three classes with
the class names of
i mean we're gonna create three divs
with the class names header
main footer so dot header
tab dot main tab
okay oh sorry and
dot footer control uh sorry tab
so we have header main and footer
okay so inside over here we're gonna
write the logo and menu items
for this project i'm gonna use the bam
naming system even if you don't
understand that
don't worry just follow along in in the
future video i will show you how you can
use the bam naming system
now write dot header dash dash
logo tab and now over here we're going
to write the logo which is
um mia ruma okay you write
mia rumor over here
and now we're gonna write the menu items
in order to do that
dot header that's that's menu
okay tap hit
enter and over here you write dot header
dash dash menu hyphen star
three okay now it's going to create us
three divs so over here you write
one then two three
okay you're right over here home on a
serial okay
portfolio
and over here we're gonna write context
all right so we are actually done with
our header section we can minimize it
ctrl s let's go and see what we have
created so far
uh we don't need this and we have
created all of this
right now don't worry about them we're
gonna style them
now we're gonna write the main section
okay so over here
now inside the main section we're going
to create two divs
image and text so image will be over
here
on the left side and the text will be on
the here right side so in order to do
that
write dot main dash dash
star 2 tap so we're gonna put the
image over here and the text will be
over here txt okay
so we're gonna clip it so we're gonna
keep this blank because we're gonna use
the background property background image
property
to insert the image over here all right
and inside the main text what we're
gonna write is
main dash dash text
hyphen star um how many how many texts
do we have
let's see one two
three and four so in order to write this
four we're going to create
four divs inside over here four tap
okay one two three four
so first one was hello and the hand wave
we're gonna
um go to google and
write hand wave hand with emo
g like this
you copy this icon from here
ctrl c paste it over here ctrl v
and over here we're gonna write um
mia roma and
we're gonna write span tag over here in
order to
convert the text to red color okay so
span span and it's gonna
create that automatically we have to
just
cut it from here and paste it over here
ctrl f and i'm a designer
was the text i guess let me check
uh it is a a designer from tokyo japan
a b e s i g n e r
f r o m and over here we're gonna write
tokyo japan
let's see what we have created so far so
these are the unstyled text over here
we're going to style them don't worry
and now we also have to write something
inside the footer
and first write dot f double o t e r
we have four social media icons dash
dash
dribble d-r-i-b-b-l-e
was dribble first let me actually check
um
no sorry instagram is first instagram
twitter
okay so insta is first
instagram
tap okay and then over here we're gonna
use the
image tag to insert the image
and dot footer in order to create
the remaining divs automatically you hit
star three tab okay instagram
twitter what was next i forgot um
dribble and be honest so d
r i b b b three b's okay don't forget
that
d r i b b b l e
three b's okay triple and behind say
the hands okay so inside this tags
we're gonna create the image tag okay
img tab
so keep it blank for now we're not gonna
insert anything
img tap okay
img tap
and img tap control f let's see what we
have created so far
it looks quite ugly but don't worry
we're gonna style them
okay so we're actually done with the
html come to
style.css and we're gonna target
the classes over here okay so right dot
container
over here and the header dot header
dot main and then dot
footer over here okay so let's first
style our header okay
ctrl s but before everything else
you need to set the height otherwise
it's not going to work i have shown this
to you
on the first project okay so 800 vh
contr
hundred vh tab so ctrl s and now let's
go back
first things first we're gonna use the
display flex property okay
now back to our project on the header
section
uh let me actually show this story live
by live i mean that
let me write over here let me show you
over here okay
so you hit ctrl b there's an extension
named
text pins d e s k p
i n s so if you click over here you can
see the window is vanishing over here so
i'm clicking here
i'm clicking here the window is vanished
so what
text pin does is let me show that to you
um here is the dex pin let me
enable it okay so i'm enabling this pin
inside this vs code and now let's click
outside
you can see that the window is not
vanishing it is staying
and on its place permanently okay so now
i'm gonna keep it over here
and i'm gonna show this to you live over
here what is happening
behind the scenes okay so now
inside the header we're gonna write d
flex okay
ctrl s and now you can see that this
menu items were here and now it has
shifted over here the default value of
flex direction is row
so write it anyways even though there
will be no
uh changes flex direction
row control s and now we can see no
changes because there's the default
value anyways
and now what we're gonna do is we want
the menu
and the logo to be stretched from the
very left to the very right
so in order to do that inside the header
you're gonna write
justify content let me bring the vs code
over here
so that you can actually see what i'm
doing justify content
it will be a space between
ctrl s and now you can see that the logo
is over here
and our menu items are over here okay
and now we also want our menu items to
behave like a row instead of behaving
like a column
in order to do that if you can recall
the head
if you can recall the menu items are
inside the header
which was that so come over here
let me maximize it to show you how to
write the selector for the
logo and the menu items to do that
and dash dash logo okay
curly braces so this one is actually
equivalent to writing
dot header
uh dash dash logo i mean look
so this end is actually getting extended
from here
to here so this is actually a shorthand
i mean shortcut
that's why sas is much better than
regular css
let's remove this in the same way we're
going to target the
menu and dash dash menu like this
ctrl s and now um we're going to style
this okay in order to do that
i mean in order to target that what you
have to do is you have to come to
end dash dash menu you write d
flex tap and flex direction say to row
which is the default value anyways
ctrl s and now we can see that this is
style like this
and let's change the font size as well
for the logo and the menu items in order
to do that
you come to the logo and you write f
size
tab okay for vw we're gonna use the vw
units okay we reload control f
and for the menu we're gonna write 2.5
vw f size tab
2.5 2.5
vw control s and we're going to use some
gaps between our menu items in order to
do that
come over here you write gap 15 pixels
you can change the value as you like
perfect it looks quite good now what
you're gonna do is you're gonna divide
the screen between the rows what i mean
by that is
you come back to vs code and over here
on the header section you write
h 10 percent okay ctrl
s and then you're gonna create border so
in order to create the border
we're creating a border over here that's
because we want to see
exactly what we are doing and where the
code is getting applied
so right border 2px
solid red control s
resize this and now we can see that this
is our header section
it is taking 10 percent of the entire
screen and we can see that how things
are working over here
you can see that this menu items are not
at the exact center over here so in
order to do that
you come to back to vs code and
and header menu not here sorry
on the header section you have to write
align
items center so you write um
sorry align
items oh sorry
center over here like this ctrl s and
now you can see that
and now you can see that the items has
moved from the top to the center
if i uh uncomment this then you can see
the difference okay
let me uncomment this ctrl s and now see
the difference okay
let me uncomment this again ctrl s and
now we can see that it has moved to the
center again
we're gonna do the same thing for the
main and the footer as well
so height we're gonna define it a
percent
eighty percentage like this ctrl
s and for the footer section height of
ten percent okay
until s so ten percent eighty percent
ten percent in total 100
and let's define the borders as well so
that we can see
what we are doing border
2px solid
black like this and for this section
border 2px solid
green like this ctrl s and let's see
what we have done so far
so this is the main and this is the
footer section
over here we're gonna have our social
media icons
okay now let's tell them first let's
insert the image so in order to do that
come back to vs
code and let me just resize this so that
you can also see
the code and the result
so what you're going to do is you're
going to click the small icon over here
and minimize
everything okay and now everything will
be on its position
okay so inside the main first of all
we're gonna target
the image and then target the text in
order to target them you write
and dash dash image curly braces
and then and dash dash text so this one
is targeting
text and this is targeting the image
okay
curly braces ctrl s and inside over here
you're gonna write
vgi you hit tab
okay so inside over here um let me
maximize this and you hit ctrl b
and inside the images folder so we're
gonna use
this image this is the portrait of this
young woman
this one over here is love the lady so
um you come over here in order to target
that exact image
you write dot slash select this
folder images folder and then in order
to
target that lovely lady you're gonna
write portrait.png or select this from
here
and now it has all right let's see
and now we can see nothing that's
because we need to set either the width
or the height depending on the
orientation
so in order to do that um come back to
vs code
first of all you need to know the
orientation how we want it we want the
image to be here
and the text to be here okay so display
flex will be
the flex direction will be row row okay
so in order to do that um come to the
main and over here you write
d flex okay tap
and flex direction would be row like
this ctrl
s and now we're gonna divide
i mean distribute the width 50 percent
for the image 50 for 50 for the text
in order to do that this is the image
okay you're gonna write
with fifty percent over here okay let me
maximize this
w fifty percent tap and then
width will be fifty percent over here
okay tap ctrl
s resize this and now we can see the
image over here it looks ugly
but if you want to work around here what
we can do is
um we have to set
the background size to contain
bg s tab to contain
control s and now it looks better but it
is getting repeated in order to stop the
repetition
you're gonna write bgr tab which is
background repeat
set it to no repeat bgr tap now repeat
ctrl s
and now we can see that the image is not
getting repeated
and over here you can see this there is
no gap okay it looks quite ugly if you
want to
give some margin over here resize this
come over here you set it to this is the
zero pixels
for the top bottom if you write five
pixels over here
then five pixels of padding i mean
margin is getting applied
here here so first top bottom
zero pixels left right five pixels
okay control s minimize this let's see
what happens
on our browser and you can see that five
pixels is getting applied over here
all right it looks quite good let's
actually remove the border from the
header because
we're done with our header um in order
to do that
onto the header and just remove them
goodbye
ctrl s let's go back and it looks good
by the way whatever you have written so
far is 100 responsive till
4k display do you want to see a demo let
me show you
f12 hit f12 and you go to
till 4k you can see that even in 4k it
looks good
why is that that's because we have used
the vw
unit which is view port width viewport
width
that's why you can see that even on the
4k display it looks quite good and look
and look i have refined no units for
this
text over here not even over here
do you even remember the font size of
our width it was
just 35 pixels and this is the default
value
and this is 4 vh this is 2.5 vh
now the background size with the value
contained which is uh let me show you
this line over here i'm sorry let me
actually find out this this line over
here the background size contain
itself is highly responsive so even if
you resize the window you can see the
image
is getting adjusted according to the
screen size you can see that it is
shrinking at the same time if you
stretch the window it's gonna enlarge it
itself so that it can fit the window
well
you can see that it is working like that
and our fonts are also responsive it is
working according to that
if you resize the window the fonts will
get smaller
and if you resize it again then it's
gonna get bigger which is highly
responsive even on the 4k display can
you imagine that
okay now um come back to vs code
and let's work with our uh we are
actually done with this section the
image and we're gonna
work with um the mobile version at the
very last
and first of all we need to change the
text okay now
you close the developer tools and you
come
to um we can we can actually remove the
border from here as well
ctrl s and on the text which is inside
this
main you create border so that we can
see
what we are trying to do okay border
we're gonna set it to red color okay 2px
solid red like this ctrl s and now we
have
the border over here so that we can
actually see
where our text are going okay now let's
come back to vs code
and we want our text to be at the
very center in order to do that you can
either use the grid
or you can use flexbox so we're gonna
use the grid because i showed you
both beforehand okay you can use
anything you want
so inside the text you write d grid
okay and place oh
let's actually use the flex okay
because a lot of you don't know how to
use the display grid
so justify content center okay
align items sorry
center like this ctrl s and now we can
see
that uh the thing is actually behaving
like a row but we want it to behave like
a column
in order to do that we're gonna write uh
flex
direction which was the default value it
was
row we want to write it column ctrl
s and now it looks quite good i mean it
looks much better than before
and now we're gonna give responsive font
sizes to each of this
text over here okay so let's come back
to vs code
and if you can recall on our html um
let's go
to the main section so the so the text
actually looks so so the text have these
classes okay in order to target those
classes
um you come to the and sorry the dot
main section and come to the text over
here
and at the bottom of this
you write and hyphen
one it is targeting
our hello text over here okay let me
actually
resize this so curly braces you're gonna
write it over here and
you're gonna set the font size to 10vh
sorry vw not v8 vw viewport
width control f and now we have a very
big
hello text over here in order to target
the remaining three lines
over here what you have to write is and
hyphen two coma and hyphen 3
comma and hyphen 4 curly braces and
we're going to set the phone size to 5
vh f size tab
5 v sorry not vh vw
okay vw control s and now it looks quite
good yeah it looks good
and i actually forgot to write something
inside the text i mean inside the image
over here
which is the background position bgp
tap let me resize it what we have to
write
is left and center don't worry i'm going
to explain that to you okay
you write left center okay
ctrl s and let me actually remove
all the guides from here and just put
guide on our image in order to do that
you come to the image
okay you write border 2px
solid red okay and remove the red color
from the text control s
and you minimize this and you can see
that
our image let me actually remove the
black color guide as well which is over
here uncomment i mean comment this
minimize and you can see that we have
some gap over here okay
that's because we're dealing with
portrait images we're not dealing with
landscape images okay
if you hit f12 let me actually show you
if i resize the window you can see that
our image is at the exact center
to the left pinned to the left center
but if you uh remove that line
which you're thinking that this is
unnecessary line of code uh let me
resize this uh drag it over
here at the top so that you can see
um let me comment this
line of code ctrl s and you can see that
image is moving from here
to the very top over here and if you
uh uncomment this ctrl s and you can see
that image is getting
over here but if you write bottom
it has in total four options top
right bottom left the first value
sorry let me
maximize this the first value works on
the x-axis
and the right value works on the y-axis
i have an
entire video on background properties
link will be given in description down
below go and check it out if you want to
make responsive images
for your responsive website i hope that
you understood the background position
property
now let's work with our footer section
okay you
cross this developer options you remove
the
guides from here okay in order to remove
the red colored guide
we can see it is here control x control
s at the bottom at the footer section
you bring the guides over here okay
control s
if you come back to the browser we can
see the guides over here
up to this point we don't need the width
over here so we can safely remove that
um in order to remove this you just come
come to the index.html we don't need to
remove anything
except you just comment this line of
code okay
ctrl s you come back to the browser and
everything is gone
and if you want to bring it back you
just uncomment this line of code over
here and it's gonna come back
okay so far so good let's insert the
images over here so in order to insert
the images
control p okay the images are over here
so
in order to locate them inside our image
tags what you have to do is you write
dot slash
images okay slash the first one is
instagram
so instagram is over here click this
similarly what you have to write
dot slash images slash this is twitter
okay you write twitter sign dot png over
here
and this is dribble similarly follow
along with me
images tab sorry uh
enter this is drippable
here is our triple and i will be
hanse dot slash images
p hunts ctrl s
control b and let's see what happens
oh you can see that this is extremely
big that's because this is
512 pixels each icon
so we need to uh we can see that this is
behaving like a column
okay like this but we want it to behave
like a row
so in order to do that come back to vs
code
um it is actually the footer section
okay so you minimize this like this
uh minimize and inside the footer
section
um in order to target all of them you
write
d grid okay tab the default value is
flexed
the default value of flex direction is
row right anyways
direction row control s minimize this
and we actually can't see any difference
because it
is extremely big so let's actually
reduce the size okay in order to do that
you follow along with me
you write square brackets class
equal to sorry a power sign equal to
double quotes you write footer f double
o t e
r dash dash what it's gonna what it is
gonna do is
it's gonna target all our classes which
contains
our images okay and curly braces over
here
and you write the image tag img curly
braces
and you're gonna set width to
5.3 vw which is the responsive size
ctrl s minimize this
uh let's see oh it is actually not
working why is that let's go and check
it out
oh sorry i wrote the wrong thing not
great it's gonna be flex
sorry sorry uh let's go and check it out
uh minimize this
ah it's working perfectly fine
okay the next thing that we're gonna do
is it is actually
not at the center okay in order to
i mean in order to place it at the
center just like the
header one which i explained to you on
the header section
so what you have to do is uh resize this
come over oh sorry
let's come over here on the footer
you write align item center okay align
items center like this ctrl s and it's
gonna be at the center
on the y-axis okay and we're going to
place some gap between our icons in
order to do that
we're going to write gap of 20 pixels
okay like this ctrl
s and we can see that we have some gaps
between our icons over here
and we're gonna place them on the right
side in order to do that we're gonna
write
justified content right or sorry
we're gonna write justify content flex
end
flex and ctrl s
and now we can see that it is over here
but we want this to be
over here not over here in order to do
that we're gonna
set some margin of 10 pixel margin right
write with me m write tap okay margin
right
set it to 10 not pixels sorry it's
percentage 10 percentage control
s and let me minimize it and you can see
that it looks quite good
i'm gonna remove the guide from here
okay in order to remove the guide you
know the drill
we just remove this from here let's
minimize this and you can see that
our website is done it looks quite
beautiful if you
hit f12 let's resize it even on the 4k
display
it looks quite good let me show you you
come to 4k you can see that
uh you focus over here it is written
4k it looks quite good and let's resize
this
using this guides over here this is
laptop large
okay it looks good and let's go to
laptop
of 1024 pixels it looks good as well
let's go to the tablet version it looks
uh quite uh
little shrunk if you resize the window
that at at some point it will look quite
ugly
oh i actually forgot to remove the
bottom from here that's why it looks
quite ugly
come to the main and image so left
bottom change it to center
control s okay it looks quite good right
now
it is loading oh yes it's over here it
resize the window
at one point you can see that the text
looks quite
horrible that's because it is very small
and it is hard to read
that's why we're gonna create a custom
media query for the mobile version so in
order to do that
um we just keep it over here as it is
and we also need to change the design
for the mobile version okay
so if you come to our uh sigma file over
here you can see
that we don't have any menu items we
don't have any menu item
options for our mobile version just the
logo over here no hello text just
the text of our miyaruma a designer from
japan
and our social media icons pretty simple
so in order to implement that um first
of all you come to our vs code
at the very bottom okay let me maximize
this at the very bottom over here we're
going to create a media query so
and media we're going to set the max
width to 650 pixels okay
max width of 650
pixels the curly braces over here
and now we can target the header along
with its logo
and text i mean the menu items in order
to do that
dot header curly braces in order to
target the logo
and dash dash logo over here
curly braces and you know drag in the
menu items dash dash
menu okay so over here you're gonna
write display
none and it's gonna remove the menu
items on the
mobile version so d non tap ctrl s
if you resize the window so you look it
over here okay it's 320 pixels okay
if you resize it uh you can see that
there is no menu items over here but
if it goes above 650 pixels then we can
see our menu
items it is 646 pixels over here you can
watch it
you can see the menu items has
reappeared
okay and if you go and we can see
everything
and now it is gone okay now we want the
logo to be at the very center in order
to do that
come back over here inside the media
query inside the
dot header selector you write justify
content center and it's gonna um
center it to at the very center over
here
now come back to vs code we also need to
change the logo font size
in order to do that you write f size tab
change it to 40 pixels ctrl s let's go
back
and we can see our logo is 40 pixels and
it looks quite good
but it's not responsive if we even
shrink it
that is because it's gonna look very
ugly if we use the vw
unit in a future video i'm gonna explain
to you all the possible css units and
what it does
so make sure to subscribe to the channel
so that you can get an update about the
video
now let's bring the image over here and
it will be
circular so in order to do that come
back to vs code
let's minimize this the header section
and over here you're gonna target the
dot
main section okay curly braces and in
order to target the image you write
and dash dash image curly braces
to target the text you write and dash
dash text over here then curly braces
ctrl
s and we're not gonna see any changes
because we didn't even do anything
okay resize the window bring this back
and
um let me keep it over here so that we
can see
actually what happens first of all
uh we need to change the orientation it
is currently on the row
but we want it to behave like a column
so in order to do that
um come over here on the main section
you write flex direction column flex
direction column like this ctrl s
and then let's see what happens we
cannot see the image okay
so in order to bring back the image you
come to this section
and you write width set it to 200 pixels
200 pixels
and set the height to 200 pixels as well
ctrl s let's see what happens um
here is our image by what we want it to
be at the very center
in order to do that come back to vs code
you're gonna write
over here okay justify content center
okay
and then align items center okay i'm not
gonna save it
let me actually resize it so that you
can see what happens if i save it
after writing those code so let me uh
keep it over here wait a second uh let
me control
f and you can see the image and the text
has appeared on the very center over
here now let's resize our social media
icons in order to do that
come back to vs code um come at the very
bottom okay
minimize this this is not done okay
we're gonna come back here and style it
okay
so at the bottom right dot footer
like this and in order to target all the
images you write
square bracket plus power sign equal
to double quotes footer
dash dash okay then curly braces will be
over here
and now you're gonna write image
and then we're gonna set the width to 45
pixels okay
and set the height to 45 pixels as well
px tab ctrl s now let's go back and see
what happens
um perfect but it looks quite ugly
that's because of
of the 10 pixels of i mean the 10
percent
margin over here okay in order to remove
the margin what you can do is come
to the footer section over here and set
the justify content to center that's
because
previously it was on the uh left side
okay and set the margin to zero pixels
okay
now it's going to work let's go back and
it looks
uh beautiful now let's resize our
text and make the image circular
so come back to vs code uh you
minimize this this is done the header
section is
done as well okay come to the main
section and over here you're gonna write
border radius hundred percent okay
percent ctrl s
and uh we can see that we have a little
bit of
distortion over here in order to fix
that what you have to do
is um you write bg
step and set from content to 100
like this ctrl s let's see our changes
now it's perfectly fine
okay we are done with our images come
back to our vs code
or we also forgot to write the
background position it should be on the
center
bgp tap center as well
center like this and it will be
perfect let me see ah yeah it's good
let's resize our text over here first of
all we're gonna set the width to hundred
percent
previously it was fifty percent w
hundred percent tap okay ctrl
s and we're gonna remove the hello text
in order to do that
and hyphen one curly braces
d not tap like this and it's gonna
remove our hello text from there
let me let us see okay you
previously we had the hello text now it
is gone
come back to vs code now target the
remaining
three other text in order to do that
right and
two comma and hyphen three comma
and hyphen four okay curly braces like
this
and we're gonna set the font size to 30
pixels f
size tab 30 pixels ctrl s
now let's see our result it looks
beautiful
this is the mobile version if you resize
it
it's going to give us the tablet version
over here let's go to the 4k
it looks quite beautiful for the 4k
version you can also customize the gaps
as you like
it is completely up to you if you resize
the window then
it looks beautiful and it resizes
when we resize the window perfectly fine
this is the 4k view this is the
large laptop view this is the laptop
view of
1024 pixels the tablet view
you can click this guides over here and
it's gonna
show us the result accordingly and then
the mobile
view this is the large if you resize it
then it looks quite
good as well i hope you understood the
second project now let's start the third
and the last project
on the third project we're gonna be
building this layout over here
so get your vs code ready now come back
to vs code and remove everything we
don't need anything we control s
delete ctrl s okay and on the index
what we are going to do is we are going
to remove the
container from here because there is a
lot of code and you write container
again
dot container tab okay
after removing everything inside the
previous container okay container
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to create three rows why is that
if you go back to our design
um not here sorry
this one if you come back to our design
we're gonna create three rows right now
because we have
row one row two row three that's why
so come back to vs code uh maximize this
you're gonna write first of all dot row
one okay in order to write it quickly
you write star
three tap okay so we have uh
row one two three okay
and now inside the rows we're gonna
create three boxes okay
in order to do that write dot vox
hyphen star three tab okay we write
one two three and inside here you write
a
b and c over here
all right similarly on the row 2 and row
3 we're going to create boxes
and then inside there we're going to
create letters okay
dot box hyphen star three
tap four five six
d a
f over here and
on the last row dot box
hyphen star three tab
seven eight nine g
h i okay ctrl s
let's go back to our browser and see
what we have created so far
and it looks quite horrible but don't
worry don't panic we're gonna style them
now come to our brows vs code
come over here you write star first of
all remove all the default
browser settings okay m0px tap
p0px tab both side tab
bobo tab okay body
say to fftab uh sense
i actually did a mistake deleting the
previous styles of our css
we should we should have not deleted
everything my apologies
my bad and now for the font size we're
gonna set it to 55 pixels so that you
can actually see
what is happening f size
tab 55 pixels ctrl s let's go back to
the browser and see what
is happening there we go we have it
now what you're gonna do is we're gonna
individually target container
row and box in order to do that you
write dot container
curly braces dot row
curly braces oh no not this one sorry
you write square bracket class
power sign equal to double quotes you
write row
hyphen okay curly braces and it's gonna
target
all our rows in order to target all the
boxes
curly braces sorry it's square bracket
class
power sign equal to box hyphen
curly braces okay now the very first
thing we're going to position our
letters from being in a column shape to
a row shape in order to do that
maximize this later the letters are
inside the box
and the box are inside the row okay
so inside the row here so what you're
gonna write is
d flex not this one sorry d
flex tab display flex set the flex
direction to row like this and
the rows are inside the column okay
sorry the rows are inside the container
and inside the container the rows should
behave
like a column in order to do that d
flex tab flex direction set it to
column like this ctrl s let's go back
ah it looks quite good and now we want
to create boxes around our letters
so first things first what we're gonna
do is we're gonna set the height of our
container
you know do that we write height hundred
vh from true s
and now in order to create the boxes we
have to set
the color first so bgc tab c4
c4 c4 okay ctrl s
and now let's see what we have created
so far
oh it looks quite terrible over here but
don't worry
and what we're going to do is we're
going to set the
width of this individual boxes and the
height
so in order to do that you're gonna
write width
so first of all bracket and right
hundred percent
and in total how many boxes do we have
we have three boxes so divide
the entire screen with divided by three
for one column i mean for one row
okay then
save it let's go back to the browser and
see what we have created
this is the result so far and let's
create some border so that we can see
what is happening
so border
two pixels solid black
like this ctrl s and we also need to set
the height as well so height
will be in the similar calculation
hundred percent
divided by three that's because we have
three boxes three rows three by three
column
i mean three by three grid layout ctrl
s and let's go back to the browser and
it looks quite terrible why is that
oh i made a mistake over here it's not
percentage value it's gonna be
viewport height or vh so
write vh over here and let's see what is
happening oh it looks
perfect in order to position the text at
the very center
what you have to write is come over to
the box
at the bottom you write d great or you
can also use
the flexbox model as well but i'm gonna
use the grid
place items right center
ctrl s let's see what we have done ah it
looks perfect as well
now we're gonna create some gap between
the rows okay this is row one
row two and this is row three okay
between the rows is gonna be 30 pixels
gap in order to do that you write gap
30 pixels over here ctrl s let's see
what we have created
we have gap between rows okay but we
also need gap between our columns okay i
mean
our boxes in order to do that come here
uh to the box not the box but inside the
row
uh you write cap 30 pixels okay ctrl s
let's see what we have created ah it
looks quite good but if you want to give
some margin
around our entire container what we can
do is
you come to at the very top over here
you can write five pixels of
margin let's resize it and looks you can
change the value as
how much you like but for this i'm gonna
set it to 5 pixels okay
but let's actually set it to a little
bit more
let's do 30 pixels and let's see what
happens it looks quite horrible oh my
god
let's set it to 10 pixels and let's see
oh it looks good not quite bad not quite
good
it looks optimum no worries
and now if we set and now if you click
f12
we can see that it looks quite ugly if
we resize it
we want to make a desktop version for
this layout
so let's set our standards to um
650 pixels okay on 650 pixels
we're going to create this layer over
here the mobile layer so in order to do
that
um come back to vs code over here
at the very bottom okay over here you're
gonna write
at the red media and set the max
width to 650 pixels like this curly
braces
and first things first let's understand
the theory okay
the rows are behaving like a column okay
which is the behavior we want on a
mobile version
but the boxes are behaving like a column
but we want the boxes to behave like a
row like this
so we need to change the behavior of our
boxes i mean the rows okay
in order to do that um come to our media
query over here
and you target the rows okay class
power sign equal to double quotes
row hyphen okay call your basis
and you set the flex
direction to
column like this okay ctrl s and let's
see what happens
resize it ah it looks quite good it is
actually not behaving
as expected so in order to change it
come back to our
vs code you remove this line of code
from here we don't need it
okay keep it keep the container inside
the media query blank
and come at the very bottom over here
you write called uh square bracket
class power sign equal to double quotes
and you
target the box i mean all the boxes and
we're to set the width
to 100 previously it was 33.33
let me show you if you scroll up uh
above the media query it was the box
over here
the width and height was 33.33 sorry
33.33
percentages each now we're going to set
it to maximum which is 100
over here okay so ctrl s resize the
window let's see what happens
ah it looks quite good as well
uh let me uh resize the window okay it
is behaving as expected
i actually mistakenly uncommented the
margin from here
let me just bring it back besides the
window it looks quite good
and you can see the results so this is
the mobile version
so we have successfully completed our
third project
so we're done with the tutorial if you
like the video give a like
share with a friend and feel free to
subscribe till then take care and i'll
see you in the next video
bye bye